et bien bonjour ça veut sa petite dose
de frissons vous arrêtez de me demander
tous les jours des serait d'horreur
d'accord si vous continuez je fais la
grève des serait d'horreur je rigole pas
un aujourd'hui trois histoires vraiment
bien je suis très heureux des histoires
d'aujourd'hui surtout qu'il y en a une
qu'on a trouvé sur le let's not mink
donc leur ai dit où des gens raconte des
expériences un peu flippante donc
l'histoire que je raconte dans cette
vidéo la fr et oui je mettrais bien en
description ci voulait raconter des
histoires dessus qui me sont arrivées
n'hésitez pas c'est l'endroit pourrait
donc aujourd'hui pour la première fois
on raconte une histoire de solid snake
[ __ ] fr et elle est incroyable mais
d'abord on commence avec l'histoire de
tomic qui lui n'est pas français
pourquoi juste avant l'histoire de tommy
découvrez d'abord l'incroyable histoire
sponsorisés de clarence
joyeux anniversaire clarence x ptdr
c'est quoi ce prénom tekki michael alias
michael le beau gosse ça mais je t'ai
jamais invités j'ai ramené des macbook
pro des iphone 12 pro et des airpod 2
pour tout le monde ok tu peux rester
beau gosse je peux avoir l'iphone oui
pour ça il te suffit de cliquer sur mon
lien en descriptions ya quoi sur ce lien
lors du mobile
où est-ce qu'il a chopé la télécommande
lors du mobile est un jeu de guerre et
de stratégie mobile gratuit le but est
de développer ton royaume ton armée
modifier la formation des troupes
recruter choisir les meilleurs héros et
créer des alliances pour imposer dans un
monde médiéval fantastique rempli de
magie et de créatures maléfiques et pour
les cadeaux en plus en ce moment il y à
une collab avec les chevaliers du
zodiaque le héros cia est offert au
téléchargement tu n'as pas répondu à ma
question j'allais y venir clavicule ne
t'en fais pas non ça se prononce
clarence je m'en tape à chaque fois que
ton château augmente de niveau tourner
la roue de la fortune pour tenter ta
chance tu tomberas peut-être sur un des
grands prix ou de cadeaux en jeu trop
cool tu es le meilleur michael burgos
bon maintenant on peut revenir à mon
anniversaire s'il vous plaît merkel
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez gagner des
cadeaux en téléchargeant lors du mobile
grâce à ton lien en description c'est
bon on sait que pourraient leur demander
de me souhaiter mon anniversaire plus
tôt ah oui pardon souhaitez tous un bon
anniversaire à clavicule à l'essai châu
dôc me travaille dans une station
service minable vous savez aux états
unis il ya énormément de stations
service et en a beaucoup qui sont
vraiment des tout petits trucs un peu
creepy minuscule pas très bien entretenu
et bientôt mis lui il travaille dans
l'une de ses stations service dont qu'il
est seul il est assis sur un tabouret
derrière le comptoir et ils attendent
des clients viennent pour payer leur
plein et précise qu autour de sa station
service si on a deux autres qui sont
beaucoup plus moderne et que donc les
clients se font plus en plus rare à la
sienne puisqu'il préfère aller dans les
trucs beaucoup plus de 9 il explique
carrément que son taf c'est plus devenu
nettoyer essayer d'entretenir commis peu
cet endroit qui est vraiment crasseux et
pas vraiment accueillir des clients à la
chaîne qui payent leur plein d'essence
bref ce jour là et les 00h30 tommy
travail de nuit est il à 6h30 à tuer il
est assis sur son tabouret derrière le
comptoir il est en train de lire un
livre et il fait tout ce qu'il peut pour
pas regarder l'horloge parce que le
temps passe très lentement soudainement
du coin de l'oeil et voit un break
s'approcher de l'une des pompes deux
hommes en sortent et se rendent à
l'intérieur de la petite boutique de
tomi l'un des deux est plutôt âgée porte
une veste en cuir et l'autre par contre
est beaucoup plus jeune il a à peu près
l'âge de tommy est hilare manteau
carhartt et des bottes de travail bref
comme il est décrit comme des gars de la
campagne rien d'inquiétant il leur dit
bonjour et leur demande en quoi il peut
les aider et puis le plus jeune des deux
hommes lui dit vous savez que vous êtes
surveillés
tommy comprends pas pourquoi il lui dit
ça et le jeune homme pointe du doigt
quelque chose à l'extérieur dehors il y
a une silhouette sombre d'un homme qui
se tient debout près d'un réverbère le
plus âgé des deux hommes expliquent
atomique qui sont passés devant la
station service il ya quarante-cinq
minutes et qu'ils ont failli écraser un
mec qui se tenait au milieu de la route
et ce mec c'est apparemment le gars et
mobile qui se trouve pas loin du
réverbère depuis des dizaines de minutes
l'homme âgé explique qu'ils ont
peut-être pensé que le mec était drogué
ou qu'ils avaient de mauvaises
intentions et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
décidé de faire demi tour et de venir
voir à la station-service si tout allait
bien pendant que les trois hommes
discutent l'inconnu se tient toujours
debout immobile dehors mais tommy il
arrive à distinguer le fait que le gars
a l'air de parler tout seul il voit sa
mâchoire bouger comme si le mec se
parlaient à lui même et c'est là qu'il
va prendre les choses en main il va
demander aux deux hommes de verrouiller
la porte d'entrée du magasin qui
constitue sa seule défense et il va leur
demander d'attendre avec lui à
l'intérieur du magasin le temps qu'il
appelle la police et c'est là qu'ils se
posent une question terrible il se dit
mais est-ce que les deux mecs qui sont
maintenant enfermée avec moi dans mon
magasin sont vraiment là pour m'aider
est ce que ces deux gars ne serai pas
complice du troisième cas près du
réverbère quoi qu'il en soit il peut
rien faire il est surveillé du coin de
l'oeil il prend son portable il appelle
la police et la police répond il lui dit
qu'elle sera sur les lieux d'ici dix
minutes dominées grandement rassuré et
raccroche et il explique aux deux hommes
que la police arrive et qui peuvent donc
circuler et les remercie encore une fois
de l'avoir prévenu les deux gars sortent
de la boutique font quelques mètres et
puis s'arrête et ils lui disent
verrouille la porte il arrive tommy se
précipite vers la porte d'entrée il a
verrouillé à double tour et en regardant
à travers la vitre y voit effectivement
la silhouette qui était jusque là
immobile sprinter vers le magasin tommy
hill est accroupi derrière le comptoir
il voit plus ce qui se passe mais il
entend et ce qu'il entend pour la
première fois c'est la voie du troisième
inconnue est cet inconnu une demande aux
deux autres où est allé le garçon
l'homme âgé lui répond et c'est de faire
gagner du temps à tommy lee lui dit
écoute il est allé dans la salle de bain
il revient immédiatement l'inconnu se
précipitent de l'autre côté du bâtiment
et de l'autre côté du bâtiment il ya une
porte qui mène à la salle de bains tommy
hill se pose plein de questions est ce
que ce mec était déjà venu en repérage
avant ce soir est-ce qu'il est venu dans
ses stations-service au hasard ou est-ce
qu'il a choisi cette station service
parce qu'il m'a vu à la caisse et s'il
est vraiment sous drogue ou est ce qu'il
est juste purement malveillants et
heureusement pour lui la police a fait
extrêmement ville puisque à ce moment-là
à un suv arrive et trois policiers
descendent immédiatement du véhicule ils
font le tour du bâtiment malheureusement
ils tombent sur personne l'inconnu a
disparu probablement quand il a entendu
les gyrophares tommy prend le temps
d'aller remercier les deux inconnus ans
qu'il a douté pendant de longues minutes
avant de comprendre qu'ils étaient
vraiment de sens côté et il n'a jamais
su qui était ce mec est pourquoi ils en
avaient après lui est ce que c'était un
gars de son entourage est ce que c'était
gratos et ce qu'il a juste pas de chance
paris n'en sais rien en revanche il a
demandé à son boss d'installer des
caméras de sécurité vers l'extérieur et
ça n'a pas été fait alors à tous les
frérots kibo seul dans des boutiques ou
qui bosse de nuit et tout courage grosse
force je serai en panique c'est l'heure
de la deuxième histoire c'est l'histoire
de anaïs notre française qu'a vécu un
truc terrible quand elle était jeune
anaïs explique que c'est maintenant une
femme elle vient d'avoir 19 ans et qu'au
moment des faits elle en avait 15
presque 16 elle entre en seconde au
lycée donc grande année et aussi elle
ouvre son compte twitter elle précise
que son nom d'utilisateur elle ne l'a
donné à personne la photo du compte ce
n'est pas une photo d'elle c'est une
image qu'elle aime bien un avatar
quelconque elle est donc anonyme elle
explique qu'elle a jamais eu beaucoup de
followers elle est monté à 30 follower
max et qu'elle suivait pas beaucoup de
gens elle sur twitter fin c'est vraiment
pas une applique à l'ouvré souvent pour
faire des trucs elles sont foutais un
peu mais un soir d'octobre elle reçoit
un message privé chelou dans ce message
c'est un mec qui se présente qui
s'appelle paul k 17 ans et qui lui
demande si elle habite bien sûr anthony
parce qu'il vient d'y emménager et qu'il
aimerait bien se faire des amis avant
son premier jour de lycées immédiatement
anaïs et les méga méfiante elle se dit
attends comment il sait que j'habite à
anthony c'est marqué nulle part sur mon
profil elle réfléchit et puis elle se
souvient qu'elle a fait un tweet qui
parlait des bus d'anthony et donc elle
en conclut que paul a probablement taper
anthony dans la barre de recherche
twitter et qu'il est tombé sur son tweet
et c'est comme ça qu'il est tombé sur
elle anaïs elle a 15 ans et vous savez
très bien quand on a 15 ans on est
vraiment en train de se construire fort
quand on rentre au lycée et elle c'est
une période qui est un peu compliquée
elle a pas trop d'amis etc et comme paul
a été polie et sympa bah lui répond elle
répond donc que oui elle habite bien
anthony qu'elle est bien au lycée là bas
et les deux ont des discussions de
jeunes ils vont parler de l'école de la
bouffe de la cantine des profs sûr qu'il
faut pas tomber parce qu'ils sont pas
cool dre vraiment une discussion
classique de lycéens mais un peu plus
tard dans la soirée paul dans cette
discussion un peu classique de lycéens
il intercale des trucs un peu moins
classiques par exemple lui demande si
elle avec loin du lycée si elle a
beaucoup de frères et soeurs si elle est
souvent au pas chez elles des questions
que tu poses patronat rarement quand tu
tchatche avec quelqu'un du lycée hamhuis
heureusement elle se rend compte et elle
ne répond tout simplement pas aux
questions bizarres de paul et voyant que
anaïs ne répond pas à ces questions là
paul évidemment il passe à autre chose
et il arrête de lui demander des trucs
déplacer les deux vont ensuite discuté
pendant deux ou trois semaines et
évidemment quand à 15 ans et que tu
parles pour la première fois un mec ou à
neuf pendant deux ou trois semaines
quotidiennement plusieurs heures par
jour et ben tu développes des sentiments
analystes ont peu à peu amoureuse de
pommes elle a très peu d'amis et
personne ne lui a jamais trop à porter
d'attention personnes a été gentil avec
elle elle explique d'ailleurs qu'elle a
su beaucoup de harcèlement et que donc à
cette époque là il suffisait d'être un
petit peu sympa avec elle pour
qu'instantanément tu soit son meilleur
ami voire plus hamhuis fait de plus en
plus confiance à paul et baissent peu à
peu sa garde et juste avant la rentrée
des vacances de la toussaint paul lui
annonce la nouvelle y débarque enfin
dans son lycée anaïs est trop heureuse
elle lui donne une heure midi et un lieu
la cour de récré bois lui répond qu'il
est trop content et qu'il a hâte mais
qu' ils aimeraient l'avoir sanquer plein
de monde autour il explique qu'il a peur
de pas la reconnaître et qui veut pas
passer sa récréation à la chercher
perdre du temps à nice compatit elle
change donc l'endroit du rendez-vous qui
est maintenant les toilettes du
troisième étage de l'école le lendemain
matin à nice se prépare elle se fait
belle comme jamais ça y est c'est le
jour j c'est la première fois qu'elle va
rencontrer paul elle compte les minutes
la récréation arrive elle court aux
toilettes du troisième étage et après
quelques minutes un homme arrive et cet
homme c'est bien paul c'est bel et bien
la photo du compte twitter à qui elle
parle depuis des semaines mais quand
même il fait un peu plus vieux de 17 ans
elle lui donne plutôt vain que 17 ils
s'entendent super bien il ya une bête
d'alchimie épaules il propose anaïs de
l'emmener manger aux quais bas à nice
refuse pas parce qu'elle a peur mais
parce qu'elle n'a pas d'argent sur elle
et qu'elle a un principe c'est qu'elle
refuse tout le temps qu on l'invite
quelque part paul a l'air déçu
évidemment mais il lui propose à la
place de la tente devant le lycée à la
sortie des cours et de la raccompagner
chez elle ce qui quand tu es au lycée
honnêtement ce fait les bg ils font ça
un peu anaïs lui explique qu'elle rende
chez elle en bus et que donc s'il veut
il peut la raccompagner jusqu'à l'arrêt
de bus et ça va être le début d'une
routine qui va se mettre en place ou
tous les jours elle va accompagner anaïs
à la sortie des cours jusqu'à l'arrêt de
bus ça va durer des semaines des
semaines au cours desquelles anaïs elle
va quand même noter un truc un peu
bizarre c'est que elle croise jamais
paul dans le lycée bon rien de mes gars
alarmant et le met ça sur le fait que
son établissement il est méga grand il
ya 1500 élèves et qu'il suffit que leurs
deux emplois du temps ne coïncident pas
pour qu'ils se croisent jamais on né le
14 décembre 7 1 jeudi au cours des
discussions anaïs se plaint à paul de
passer la soirée seul parce que son père
est en voyage pour le travail son frère
fait que de sortir chez des amis sa
soeur était en voyage scolaire et sa
mère travail ce jour là jusqu'à très
tard il ya vraiment une sorte d'
alignement des astres ce jour-là pour
qu'anaïs soit seule chez elle alors
ayant peut-être qu'au moment où il dit
ça à paul il se parle depuis des mois
c'est plus un inconnu paul là c'est
vraiment un gars extrêmement proches
d'anaïs havrais fleurs un vrai creux
bref à l'issue de cette discussion anaïs
retourne en cours et en fin d'après midi
à la sortie des cours paul vient la
chercher et la compagne jusqu'à l'arrêt
de bus comme tous les jours depuis des
mois elle monte dans le bus elle met des
écouteurs à lui fait un signe de la main
le bus par deux arrêts plus tard à nice
descend donc du bus et en descendant du
bus elle a un feeling bizarre elle à ce
fameux truc désagréable dans l'estomac
quand t'es pas bien quand on instinct te
dis attention anaïs mais on pose sa
musique mais elle garde ses écouteurs
pour faire genre qu'elle entend rien de
ce qui se passe autour d'elle et c'est
ce move qui lui a probablement sauvé la
vie elle quitte la grande avenue pour
s'engouffrer dans le quartier
pavillonnaire dans lequel elle habite
pendant qu'elle marche elle entend
quelques mètres derrière elle des bruits
par anaïs mais discrètement à la main
dans sa poche pour attraper les clés de
chez elle elle arrive devant chez elle
elle met la clé dans la serrure elle
ouvre à toute vitesse et l désactive la
la ce qui montre qu'elle est bel et bien
seule chez elle à partir de là les
soulager et elle s'assoit dos à la porte
d'entrée elle se lève elle regarde à
travers la vitre et sur la route devant
sa maison ya paul vol la regarde dans
les yeux d'un air malsain c'est plus le
gars mignon et gentille qu'il était dans
ses discussions avec les précédents -
les deux se regardent et anaïs elle en
full angoisse parce que elle sait que
paul est au courant qu'elle est seule
chez elle paralysée par la peur à nice
reprend contrôle de son corps et elle
court dans sa cuisine pour attraper un
couteau elle retourne devant sa porte
d'entrée épauler maintenant juste de
l'autre côté en train de bourriner la
porte anaïs fonce vers la porte d'entrée
et la plaque pour être sûr que le verrou
ne saute pas sous les coups de poing et
au même moment le voisin d'anaïs se
garent sur les trottoirs et en voyant sa
pole pense que c'est la merde à nice 40
plutôt prévu et part en courant pendant
deux heures anaïs attend chez elle seule
dans le noir couteau dans la main et
téléphone dans l'autre et lorsqu'elle
entend la voiture de sa mère arrivée
elle part en courant dans sa chambre et
elle fait mine de rien anaïs elle est
tellement traumatisée elle a tellement
honte de ce qui vient d'arriver alors
qu'elle a aucune raison d'avoir honte
c'est juste quelqu'un qui a abusé d'elle
cas étaient manipulateurs qui a été
patient quelqu'un qui rentrait dans son
cerveau d'adolescentes fragile mais
comme souvent dans ce genre d'histoire
est la honte et donc elle en parle à
personne les jours suivants sur twitter
paul la harcèle de messages il la menace
et l'insulté à tel point qu'à nice le
bloc et supprime la conversation mais
rapidement elle est suivie par des
comptes twitter qui viennent d'être
créées dont le nom d'utilisateur est une
suite de chiffres suivi de la lettre p
évidemment paul et derrière ses comptes
et à chaque fois qu'elle en blocs 1 elle
est suivie par un nouveau qui le renvoie
les mêmes sache au total anaïs va
bloquer une cinquantaine de ses comptes
mais comme ça continue elle va carrément
supprimé son compte twitter elle s'est
aussi renseigné auprès des autres élèves
de la classe de paul qui lui ont dit
n'avoir tout simplement jamais entendu
parler d'un paul vous avez compris en
fait paul il n'était pas du tout lycéen
il n'a jamais été dans ce lycée juste il
arrivait à rentrer dans le lycée le midi
pour le rendez vous devant les toilettes
et le soir il venait devant le lycée
pour l'accompagner jusqu'à l'arrêt bus
mais c'était pas un lycéen en fait bref
tous les doutes d'anaïs se confirme et
elle décide de ne pas porter plainte en
premier lieu parce qu'au moment des
faits elle est mineure et que donc si
elle va porter plainte elle doit en
parler à ses parents et elle n'a pas
envie d'en parler à ses parents et aussi
elle veut pas porter plainte parce
qu'elle n'a aucune preuve étant donné
qu'elle a supprimé son compte twitter
c'est des trucs qui arrivent beaucoup
plus souvent qu'on le pense le fait
d'être abordée par des inconnus
malveillants sur internet alors elle dit
il faut pas devenir parano mais il faut
avoir ça en tête et rester prudent il ya
des signes qui ne trompent pas troisième
histoire manor elle était longue la
deuxième la troisième histoire c'est
celle de magali elle a lieu aux états
unis ça s'est passé deux ans avant
qu'elle raconte à l'époque elle
travaillait dans un hôtel elle
travaillait de nuit comme pour tommy à
la station service et quand il
travaillait nuit elle était seule c'est
à dire elle était à la réception et y
avait personne d'autre dans l'hôtel que
l et les clients qui dort au moment des
faits anaïs est presque à la fin de son
service et ce soir là il s'est pas passé
grand chose elle a juste enregistré un
groupe de gens qui faisaient un
séminaire c'est tout en regardant au
loin magali voix sur le parking d'une
camionnette arrivé et ce gars est un
gars sort de la voiture et il est
couvert de saleté magali elle s'en fout
un peu elle a l'habitude d'accueillir
des clients qui sont des gars qui font
des travaux manuels qui sont des
ouvriers etc généralement ils viennent
après une grosse journée travail donc
c'est très fréquent que les gars soient
hyper tâche est pas propre quand il
arrive à l'hôtel l'a connu arrive à
l'accueil une demande une chambre magali
prend ces infos pour l'enregistrer il
s'appelle michael est lui demande sa
plaque d'immatriculation pour
enregistrer le véhicule puisse qui
stationnent sur le parking de l'hôtel et
mickaël refuse et demande une chambre au
deuxième étage près de l'escalier de
secours pour pouvoir s'y rendent et
fumer des clopes quand il en a envie bon
rien d'anormal magali procède au
paiement et lui donne la clé de sa
chance mickaël prend l'escalier avec ses
sacs et quelques minutes plus tard il
est de retour à la réception et l'accuse
magali lui avoir donné une clé qui ne
fonctionne pas classique il a dû mettre
la carte dans sa poche près de son
téléphone ou de ses clés c'est la
démagnétisée bref la clasico magali
magnétise donc une seconde carte sauf
que cette fois elles l'accompagnent au
deuxième étage jusqu'à sa chambre pour
lui ouvrir et lui montrer que ça marche
bien elle redescend à la réception et
contrairement à la station service de
tommy l'hôtel est très bien équipée en
caméra et en regardant le retour caméra
du parking elle se rend compte que la
camionnette de michael n'est plus sur le
parking sauf qu'elle vient d'accompagner
michael dans sa chambre c'est impossible
qu'ils soient descendus et qu'il ait
bougé la camionnette sans qu'elle le
voit 20 minutes passent au cours
desquelles il se passe rien d'anormal eu
michael traverse de nouveau le hall
principal et se rend à l'extérieur sur
le parking elles le voient s'allumer une
clope rien d'anormal et puis michael
revient dans l'hôtel en courant
cigarette à la bouche donc magali lui
dit si tu veux fumer c'est dehors dans
l'hôtel c'est interdit michael jette sa
clope parterre l'écrasent et s'assoit
dans le canapé de la réception devant la
télé magali comprend que le mec est
chelou et en plus ils regardent très
fréquemment vers l'entrée principale du
hall il est agité il a l'air un peu
paranoïaque et des fois ils se parlent
un peu à lui-même ça va durer 30 minutes
30 minutes à l'issue desquelles magali
décide d'aller voir michael et de lui
dire écoute et vous n'avez pas le droit
de rester dans le hall à cette heure-là
donc s'il vous plaît remonter dans votre
chambre ce qui est écoutez moi bien un
pur mensonge il a totalement le droit
d'être là et de regarder la télé mais
elle est très méfiante parce que le mec
est vraiment chaud michael monte au
deuxième étage et avant de rentrer dans
sa chambre et redescend voir magali et
lui dit qu'il a oublié où se trouve sa
chambre et qu'il a besoin qu'elle le lui
montre et elle lui réexplique où je
trouve sa chambre à savoir au deuxième
étage à gauche mais qu'at elle remonte
les escaliers et cette fois il trouve sa
chambre et claque la porte dix minutes
plus tard il redescend voir magali et
cette fois ils l'accusent d'avoir volé
son téléphone portable anaïs comprend
qu'elle est en danger elle met un
tournevis dans sa poche et elle se rend
au niveau des canapés sur lesquels il a
passé 30 minutes pour fouiller entre les
coussins voir si son téléphone aurait
pas glissé de sa poche surprise elle
tombe pas sur son téléphone mais sur sa
carte de crédit elle lui donne et
mickaël évidemment l'accusent d'avoir
volé sa carte de crédit là c'en est trop
pour magali elle lui dit écoutez si vous
continuez de m'accuser de vous voler des
trucs c'est simple j'appelle la police
et on règle ça y'a pas de soucis michael
lui arrache sa carte bleue des mains et
il sort une nouvelle fois sur le parking
magali retourne à l'accueil derrière son
ordinateur et 20 minutes plus tard
michael re rentrer dans l'hôtel cette
fois il est beaucoup plus calme il va
voir magali et lui demande de venir
l'aider parce qu'il a un problème avec
sa voiture sauf que souvenez vous la
voiture avec laquelle il est arrivé
n'est plus sur le parking de l'hôtel
elle comprend donc que le mec inventent
des trucs pour essayer de la faire
sortir sur le parking dans quel but elle
en sait rien mais elle sait que ça cache
un truc magali refuse le foie est une
nouvelle fois mickaël retourne sur le
parking de l'hôtel elle est seule dans
cet hôtel il est à rien mais qui est
clairement menaçant elle se démerde
depuis un moment pour refuser toutes les
demandes du gars mais elles sont qu'à un
moment où l'autre il va péter un câble
elle retombe sur son ordinateur et elle
voit que michael n'est plus sur le
parquet et d'ailleurs elle voit que
michael n'est plus nulle part et puis
sur la caméra du parking elle voit un
autre véhicule que la camionnette
qu'elle a vu arriver plus tôt
immédiatement elle appelle un des hôtels
aux alentours elle lui donne la plaque
d'immatriculation du véhicule en
question et on lui demande si cet hôtel
là a déjà enregistré ce véhicule la
réponse est non elle a les yeux rivés
sur la caméra de surveillance à tel
point qu'elle se rend pas compte que
michael est de retour dans le rôle elle
lève la tête et une fois de plus elle
lui explique qu'il doit soit allé dans
sa chambre soit quitter les lieux et là
mickaël lui hurle dessous il lui dit tu
dois sortir dehors avec moi maintenant
et m'aider et d'un coup mickaël sprint
au loin sur le parking et disparaît et
du champ de vision de magali et des
caméras de surveillance magali elle est
choquée et il lui reste dix minutes
avant l'arrivée de la prochaine en prix
celle qui va prendre le relais à la
réception c'est les dix minutes les plus
longues de sa vie ses dix minutes
pendant lesquelles elle pense que
michael va revenir et cette fois d'en
arriver aux mains eva la kidnapper de
force heureusement ce n'est jamais
arrivé elle explique ce qui s'est passé
à sa collègue qui risque lui de croiser
michael et elles vont toutes les deux
verrouiller les portes d'entrée du hall
avec un panneau expliquant que si les
clients veulent rentrer à l'intérieur il
faut appeler la réception et elle rentre
chez elle en sûreté le lendemain elle
appelle ses bosses et ses bosses tu
expliques que michael n'est jamais
revenue dans sa chambre prendre ces sacs
et oui souvenez vous ils étaient venus
avec des sacs qu'il a déposée dans sa
chambre un mois plus tard magali est de
nouveau à la réception sauf que cette
fois il ya des collègues dans l'hôtel
elle n'est pas seule et qui franchit la
porte d'entrée du hall michael michael
vient la voir et lui demande des
nouvelles à propos des affaires qu'il a
laissé dans sa chambre un mois plus tôt
et il lui demande aussi s'il peut
réserver une chambre elle garde son sang
froid lui explique un employé va lui
amener ses affaires mais qu'en revanche
et n'a plus droit d'entrer dans cette
propriété autre chose que magali
remarque c'est que cette fois il est
arrivé à l'hôtel en suv ce qui
correspond ni à la camionnette qu'elle
avait vu un mois plus tôt ni deuxième
véhicule qu'elle avait vu un mois plus
tôt rodez sur le parking mais qu'elle
récupère donc ses affaires et 120 mais
après qu'il soit parti magali elle
réalise un truc il l'a appelé par son
prénom alors au début elle s'est dit bah
c'est normal j'ai un badge et mon prénom
est marqué dessus sauf que ce jour là
elle avait oublié de mettre son match
mais qu'at elle se souvenait de son
traîneau un mois après sa première
apparition dans l'hôtel elle en a donc
conclu que c'était bel et bien un gars
creepy qu'il a ciblé qu'il a
probablement vu au loin à la réception
et qui ce soir là lui voulait du mal
mais n'a pas osé passer à l'acte magali
elle n'a plus jamais travailler seul le
soir à l'hôtel sans la présence de son
petit ami qui la conduisait jusqu'à
l'autel et qui est resté avec elle n'a
duré de son service où elle s'est
retrouvée seule dans l'hôtel voilà
messieurs dames maintenant c'est simple
dès que gérer deux nuits dans un endroit
les employés je leur ferai des sourires
je le redis je reviens tu veux un café
frérot tout va bien du coup je réécris
pis ils appelleront afrique fait chier
j'espère que ces trois histoires vous en
plus je crois que c'était un ses droits
plutôt long aujourd'hui habituellement
vous m'en voulais parce qu'ils sont trop
courts écouter aujourd'hui vous devriez
être rassasié en terme d'histoire
d'horreur passé merveilleuse soirée et
une délicieuse nuit à très vite
[Musique]